Now, before we can utilize the water tools in any of our levels, we need to create a
level that has a landscape actor in it.
So to do this, what we're going to do is we're first going to create a basic level by coming
here to the editor, going to File, New Level, and then selecting the basic from the New
Level dialog.
Once we have done that, we're going to go ahead and delete this static mesh here.
So I'm just clicking on the floor and pressing Delete.
And the next thing that we need to do is we're going to go up to our landscape and we're
going to add a new landscape.
The one thing that we need to make sure that our landscape does have enabled is this Enable
Edit Layers.
The reason we need this is this is going to enable the option for our landscape to have
multiple layers.
And our water tools work on these layers as the water tools can directly affect the look
and shape of our landscape.
So let's go ahead and set that up now.
So again, we're going to come up here to our selection mode and we're going to go to landscape
we're going to make sure we're on Create New Landscape.
We have Enable Edit Layers on by default and then we're just going to hit Create.
And once we've done that, you can see here we have our landscape ready to go.
So we're going to get out of landscape mode and get ready to, in the next section, explore
the different tools that make up the water tools.